austin and she'll be starting as an
assistant professor at purdue university
computer science
and she works in machine learning and
she's a bayesian
so
so we're very excited to hear what she
has to say
that's an interesting practice
for the client introduction um so thanks
for having me i'm really happy to be
here today to discuss with you how to
learn from massive amounts of data in a
scalable and reliable way
so this talk is based on joint work with
my phd advisor chris and amazing
collaborators cooper chang yeo and
junior andrew and the die
so i guess we all agree that a whole
bunch of errors are revolutionized by
data
for example in society people use data
to design a policy and predict the
impact of it
or analyze economics and study how the
market system works
in science people use data to study the
expression of gene or the
characteristics of a planet
in technology the newest generation of
machine learning system is largely
driven by the explosion of data
we will know examples including
comparison and speech recognition so
will data are key to solving these big
problems um they're actually useless
until we turn them into useful discovery
prediction or decision
so as nowadays data becomes larger and
larger and more complicated
it poses a question so how can we learn
from big and complex data effectively
and efficiently
so one of the most powerful and the
principled frameworks to learn from data
is by properties modeling which takes
the intrinsic uncertainty of the real
world into consideration and uses
statistical language to describe the
world
a typical properties modeling pipeline
can be summarized as the following
we start off with some data
and we build the model with parameters
data
the model defines a likelihood which
describes how the data interacts with
the parameters and how the data can be
observed from this system
and the model also includes a prior
distribution over the parameters
to express our prior knowledge before
observing the data
now taking the data and model together
we can infer the parameters from the
data
by base rule
we can get the posterior distribution p
of theta given the data set
which is proportional to the likelihood
times the prior so at this step we are
extracting information from the data to
yin for annual parameters and transfer
our prior knowledge to posterior
knowledge
finally we can use this learn model to
do downstream applications such as
prediction decision making or scientific
discovery
so of course every step matters in this
pipeline such as
how to collect the data and how to build
the model
but today i'm going to focus on the
algorithmic
aspect of this pipeline
assuming that we are given the data and
the model how can we infer the
parameters
from the data both accurately and
efficiently
to do this inference step
there are existing tools we can use
and these tools can be evaluated across
two important features
the ability to work with
big data and large models and the
ability to provide reliable and
trustworthy results
so now we can situate existing tools on
this diagram
on one hand we have a optimization or
maximum posteriori
so which approximates the posterior
distribution by just a point mass
so it is highly like scalable and can
work with deep neural networks millions
of data but it is not reliable because
it completely discards uncertainty and
the point estimate is very sensitive to
disturbance
on the other hand we have a
markov chain monte carlo
which is guaranteed to converge to the
true posterior regardless the shape of
the posterior
however it is just too slow to work with
modern models and big data
in between we have variation inference
which use
simple approximations such as a gaussian
approximation
to the true posterior
recently a class of exact mcmc methods
emerges so in order to gain scalability
they introduce a synthetic bias to the
inference results
therefore significantly sacrifice
reliability
so clearly there's a trade-off in the
existing inference methods the more
the more reliable and accurate the
results are the more computation and the
time it will take
so this
existing tradeoff forces users to choose
between
expensive exact methods and
bias the scalable ones
so our goal is to do
both scalable and reliable inference
and to achieve this we are mainly
working on uh two lines of work
the first line uh is focusing on uh
general and theoretical grounded
approaches
so we have um scale
we have make inference scalable by
taking the advantage of mini batch
approximation will at the same time
theoretically guarantee is crackness and
efficiency
and the second line is to do efficient
inference for reliable deep learning so
deep neural networks have been
criticized for being overconfident
and easily food
by analyzing key challenges we have
developed methods
to keep the high performance and high
scalability while at the same time
improving its reliability
for today's talk for the first line i
will introduce person mini batching
which is a general framework to make
classic co-inference methods scalable
while keeping their correctness
and for the second line i will introduce
cyclical sgmcmc
which is a highly efficient mcmc method
to do inference in deep learning
okay let's uh go to the first part
so i will use metropolis testing as an
example to introduce a person mini
batching framework later i will show you
how we can apply it to gibbs sampling
metropolising is one of the most basic
inference algorithms and is also the
oldest mcmc method
it was named one of the top 10 most
influential algorithms of 20th century
and not only image itself is widely used
it is also an important building block
in many other mcmc methods
specifically recall that in a standard
probabilistic modeling setup
we are given the data set and model the
goal is to estimate the posterior so we
can rewrite the posterior distribution a
little bit such that it is proportional
to the x of a sum of old energy
functions ui
and metabolic systems estimate a
posterior by sampling from it
so first it generates a proposal data
prime and accept it with some
probability depending on a sum over the
entire data set
um so image is guaranteed to be correct
in the sense that if we run the chain
long enough it will converge to the true
posterior
the intuition of image is like this so
we are at some position theta then
according to the proposal distribution
we get a candidate position theta prime
to move two but in order to make sure
that we are sampling from the right
distribution we only move to a theta
prime with some probability and this
probability is depending on the entire
data set
so as you can see a challenge for image
big data is that this accept reject step
can be very costly when the data set is
large
a common way to address this is to
approximate this acceptance probability
by a mini batch of data
a previous minibatch method can be
divided into two classes depending on
whether the posterior distribution is
preserved
and the first class is the exact method
which means that they may not preserve
the true posterior
so this method introduces asymptotic
bias to the inference but the benefit is
that they usually have mild requirements
and the second class is exact methods
meaning that they are guaranteed to
preserve the posterior
however they often
have strong constraints on the posterior
distribution and are usually not
scalable
so given these pros and cons it is we do
not know which
method we should use in practice and
whether this current tradeoff is
unavoidable
so we provide answers to these questions
and show that it is essentially possible
to achieve a much better trade-off so we
can keep the exactness we'll at the same
time significantly improve scalability
the first question we study is
is it important to be exact
well inexact methods are popular in
practice because they are simple and
fast it is not entirely clear what
how the synthetic bias would affect the
inference results
we showed that
the answer is yes
we analyzed in
exact methods and prove that they are
not reliable
so in this theorem we show that the
total variation distance and the kl
divergence between the
stationary distribution of any exact
methods and the true posterior can be
arbitrarily large
so this theorem immediately um suggests
that
any exact methods can be arbitrarily
wrong and because of this we should use
exact methods
especially on high impact and safety
critical applications to ensure um
trustworthy results
so we um verify our theme empirically uh
where we tested two year exact methods
on a random work problem
and the first panel clearly shows that
the stationary distribution of e-exact
methods diverges significantly from the
target distribution which is the uniform
distribution
and the second panel shows that this
divergence can be arbitrarily large by
increasing the number of states
so therefore this example verifies our
theorem that
exact methods can be arbitrarily bad
so by analyzing yin exact methods we
show that it is important to be exact to
guarantee the correctness
however how can we make exact methods
scalable
to answer this question we propose a
framework called person mini batching
let's start off with the standard
acceptance probability in muchability's
testings where we have to sum over all
the energy functions
so we want to replace this expensive sum
by a chip sum which only involves a mini
batch
and to achieve this goal and inspired by
auxiliary variable method we augment
each
ui with auxiliary variable xi
and after this augmentation if we can
make most eyesight to be 0 then we
naturally only need to sum over a mini
batch of ui
because if size 0 then the term
containing ui will disappear in the
acceptance probability
and finally to give us a little bit more
freedom in design we replace the
difference by a function mu i of theta
and theta prime
so now if we can find such variables s i
and functions mu i we naturally enable
mini batching when computing this
acceptance probability
so now the question is how to find such
variables and functions
the first requirement is that
sampling auxiliary variables must be
quick because if it is as slow as
computing the original sum it defeats
the purpose of introducing them in the
first place
unfortunately poisson variables can
satisfy this requirement
there's a way to
sample a set of personal variables fast
but first to sample one person variable
and then sample from a multinomial
distribution
because of this we set aside to follow
personal distribution
and this is also why this framework is
called personal mini batching
our next question is how to define these
poisson parameters lambda i and function
mu i
so we define them to
ensure the exactness of the inference
results
it is well known that if the microchain
satisfies a detailed balance it is
guaranteed to convert to the true
posterior
so the detailed detail balance means
that
the probability of theta times the
transition probability from theta to
theta prime
is equal to the probability of theta
prime times the transition probability
from theta prime to theta
so uh
the function mu y and the lambda i will
appear in the transition probability t
and we define them to satisfy this
equation
question
lambda is the poisson parameter for a
variable s i
great so after defining lambda i and mu
i to satisfy detailed balance we have
finished everything in this construction
so in summary we have find desirable
variables and functions and therefore we
naturally enable
uh mini batching with computing this
acceptance probability
i will call this algorithm tune image
and by design it is guaranteed
exact
so now i will show you
tuna image is also guaranteed
scalable so the overall cost of running
an algorithm is equal to
the cost of per stack times the number
of steps it requires
to ensure that the overall cost is small
on big data we need to consider both
terms
for the first term
we can show that the batch size of tune
image is upper bounded and the upper
bound is much less than the data set
size
in most cases
and for the second term we have a
theorem showing that qnamh is at most a
constant factor slower than standard
image and faster convergence means less
number of steps are required to converge
so as far as we know this is um the
first such balance for mini batch
majority systems to rigorously
categorize how mini batching affects
the convergence rate of a marker chain
therefore by showing these two bounds we
have proved that
tune image is guaranteed scalable
after developing a new algorithm we ask
a folder question so is it possible to
develop a better exact method
like should we continue devoting our
time on finding new algorithms
well so in terms of asymptotic
optimality the answer is no
so we got answer by analyzing how
efficient and exact matter can be
so in this theorem we provide a lower
bound on the batch size that any exact
methods are required to
retain hexagons and fast convergence
so we basically will give a lower bound
on the backsides exact method required
and there are two main takeaways for
this theorem so as far as we know this
is the first theorem to provide a bound
for the performance of any exact methods
and this theorem also implies that tune
image is asymptotically optimal in terms
of the batch size
now let's see some empirical results so
here
we test the tuna image gaussian mixture
and i showed that's the estimation
dynamics on this task
so we can see that compared to other
exact methods um two damage is the
fastest to converge because it has the
smallest smallest symmetric ko
divergence given the same running time
and we also test uh two damage on a
logistic regression on amnest so here
the task is to classify dj7 and 9 and
again we can see that 10 mh has the is
the fastest to converge since it has the
highest test accuracy given the same
runtime
so far i have shown you how to do
scalable exact maturities testings but
there are many other inference methods
which are suitable for different
tasks it turns out that
pursue mini batching essentially offers
a general recipe to make classical
inference methods both scalable and
reliable
so now i will show you the generality of
pursuing mini batching by applying it to
gibson
which is another fundamental inference
algorithm
so um deep sampling is first proposed by
german brothers in 1984 and it has been
regarded as the de facto inference
algorithm for graphical models
it has wide applications such as
restricted bosman machine physical
modeling topic modeling and has been
used in many real-world systems such as
deep dime and snorkel
specifically let's consider a vector
graph
where the joint distribution of theta is
defined uh to be proportional to the x
of a
sum of a set of vectors phi i
so for example in this simple factor
graph we have three variables 5 1 2 5 3
and 4 factors oh sorry three variables
theta 1 to theta 3 and the four factors
of 5 1 2 5 4.
and the relation among them are defined
by the connecting edges
we also define uh aj to be a set of
vectors that
depends on variable data j
so for example for this
graph a1 contains 1 2 3 because
5 1 2 5 3 all depend on beta 1.
example from this joint distribution
that gives something
in the first step the algorithm selects
a variable to sample at random
and
then it computes all the factors
depending on the selected variable to
construct a conditional distribution
so for example if we
if the algorithm select data one to
resample at the first step and in the
second step it needs to compute a five
one to five three in order to construct
this conditional distribution
and finally it resample a variable from
this conditional distribution
unlike much of this testing gibbs
sampling doesn't need to compute
acceptance probability because the
acceptance probability is always one
however
constructing this proposal distribution
which is the conditional distribution
is expensive because we need to sum our
set of factors
as you can see deep something also has
the scalability issue
when the factor set is large
it will be very expensive
to construct this conditional
distribution in the second step
and a natural idea to reduce this cost
is to
subsample factors when computing this
conditional distribution
so here i will show you that
we can apply the same idea of pursue
mini batching to enable using a mini
batch of factors
so now let's follow the same steps to
make gibbs something scalable
so after the algorithm selects variable
to resample
we augment a auxiliary poisson variable
to each vectors in the conditional
distribution just as what we did in uh
javis testings
and now only if
si is not zero we need to compute the
corresponding vector phi i
because if uh
phi because if iso is zero the term
containing
phi i will disappear in the
conditional distribution
finally to give us a little bit more
freedom in design we replace phi i by a
function mu i of theta
um
so again i show that we by following the
same uh recipe we can make uh gibbs uh
oh sorry so by satisfying the detail
balance we again get the definition for
si and miui
so but yeah by following the same recipe
of pursue mini batching framework
where you can make deep sampling
scalable
and we call this algorithm person gives
and it also has guaranteed
exactness and the scalability
similar to tuna image
so let's link back to the diagram we
have before by developing pursuit mini
matching we push the frontier of this
tradeoff by keeping the asymptotic
correctness
will at the same time significantly
improve
scalability
and our work in this slide also
includes armgold where we develop a
exact scalable gradient based mcmc
method by infrequently using much of
these hastings
uh any questions for the first part
um does your poisson give sampling
depend on the grass structure at all
sampling you select the subset of the
variables right
and does that subset depend on the graph
structure or does it
or does it just depend on the
poisson example
uh yes so the distribution of the
personal variables depends on the
structure of the graph so yes it depends
on the structure of the word
so you showed something about logistic
regression that you were accelerating in
the previous slide i didn't understand
what exactly you would think
uh
so for the logistic regression
yeah yeah
um so yeah we showed the test accuracy
versus the runtime
so you are you're using your algorithm
in for infinite for classification for
inference yes yes
to you for the the parameters of the
model
so are you planning like hdd
oh we are doing base and you press
medium larger sigma brush
so
let's start the second part
efficient mcmc for inference in deep
learning
um so there has been a lot of excitement
on deep learning because of this amazing
performance on many applications such as
image detection machine translation
recommender systems game playing and
robotics
however a key question remains to be
answered
is it reliable can we
safely apply to more and more
applications and trust its results
now let's consider question to see why
we need better inference for deep
learning
imagine that you are traveling to
seattle and would like to know more
about the city so where will you go in
order to get a comprehensive
so maybe some of you will go to space
needle so that you can get an overview
from the top of the tower
or maybe somewhere or some of you will
go to um discovery park so that you can
enjoy the natural scenery
or maybe some of you will go to the
farmer's market to taste the local food
no
or
go to like the museum to get to know the
culture
well so apparently it is not possible
uh to get the complete understanding of
the city by going only one place
so in order to know
deeply uh we should we should explore as
many places as we can since these places
provide a complementary understanding of
the city
so this is similar to the reason why
deep learning especially needs reliable
inference so the landscape of
deep learning is very complicated and
highly multimodal
um
which means that the loss or the
posterior does not strongly favor any
one of the solution
so there are many many equally good
solutions in the law surface
and the single point estimate is not
sufficient to reflect the true solution
space
moreover each modes are essentially
corresponding to different
representations of the data so they are
now simply due to waste mattresses or
rescaling so as a result combining these
different representations
will lead to better accuracy and
calibration as demonstrated in many
previous works
however in order to handle deep models
um
and big data deep neural networks are
often trained with stochastic
optimization methods
which use a single point as the estimate
so this leads to
wrong uncertainty estimation and
unreliable prediction such as being
overconfident on answering data and
easily fooled by adversarial examples
so to honestly reflect the true
landscape we need better posterior
approximation
to provide better point estimate
uncertainty representation and the
calibration
so now the question is how to get it
the stochastic gradient mcmc provides a
promising direction to do inference in
deep learning so it has close connection
with stochastic gradient descent
in s3d
we update the parameter following the
negative gradient direction
s3d uh works like this so the loss
decreases around the pass
and
uh and the model converts to a local
minimum
sgmcmc has similar updates but
additionally adding a properly scaled
gaussian noise
uh so as you can see from the animation
it not only converts but also randomly
explore the parameter space to provide
uncertainty estimation
to improve sampling efficiency previous
work has introduced momentum
preconditioners and various reduction
techniques however they are still not
efficient enough at exploring
multi-modal distributions and they often
get trapped in some local mode and
require impractical number of iterations
to move across most
now let's go back to the traveling
scenario and consider a second question
so since we want to explore city uh how
can we do it efficiently so when you
explore by car or on foot
so if by car you can move fast among
places but you will miss the detail of
each place
if our food you can carefully
investigate each place but you will
spend a long time to move to another one
so this is similar to the inefficiency
um problem of sgmcmc so we argue that
the key reason is the decreasing steps
as schedule it typically requires
so sgmcmc requires
decreasing steps as
to make sure that the approximation
error is zero in the case of infinite
computational time
however in a practical limited time a
small sepsis results in slow
mixing in fact the step size controls
the sampler's behavior in two ways
the magnitude to deterministic drift
towards high density regions
and the level of injecting noise to
randomly explore the parameter space
therefore a small step says reduce
reduces both important abilities
resulting in like a large number of
iterations to move across most
and to solve this problem we propose to
replace the traditional decay by a
cyclically changing one
so the blue curve
is the traditional decay and the red
curve represents the proposed cyclical
step steps and schedule
so um
the
steps varies periodically with respect
to the iteration where epochs and the
period is automatically controlled by a
cosine function
so think about the problem of exploring
the city the most efficient way will be
a driving car to move among places and
when reaching a place
working inside place to
get to know the details
so the philosophy of our method is
similar
the cyclical steps as schedule combines
the benefits of fast moving and also
fast scale exploring
specifically our methods operates in two
stages
and the first stage is
exploration
when the steps is is large
we regard this phase as effective
brilliant mechanism
where we encourage
sampler to take large moves and leave
the current mode
and the second stage is sampling
when the step size is small the sampler
explores one local mode and do local
dusty estimation
so in summary um the cyclical subset
schedule
can like move fast among different modes
efficiently and also characterize one
local mode accurately
to improve the sampling efficiency we
introduced a system temperature for
exploration and exploitation
so in the exploration stage we set
temperature to be zero such that
sampling becomes optimization so we
perform optimization as a efficient
burden such that the sampler can be
close to a mode before sampling stage
and in a sampling stage we set
temperature between 0 and 1 such that
the samples are from a sharper posterior
because from empirical observation we
find that this gives better results
so we hypothesis that um a smaller
tampering helps due to the over
parameterization of neural networks so
we can treat temperature as a
hyperparameter to
reflect the belief that the model
capacity can be
misspecified to theoretically understand
our method we provide a weak convergence
bound as well as one since then um
the convergence bound under waterstand
distance
so this results give theoretical
guarantees for
cyclical sgmcmc
but please note that
unlike person mini batching in the first
part csjmc may have a synthetic bias
and how to
remove this bias and do a fast exact
inference in deep learning is still an
open question
now let's see some empirical results
we tested a mixture of 25 gaussians to
simulate the scenario of highly
multimodal distributions
so we can see that hgld which is a
standard and sgmcmc method
gets trapped in some local modes and it
can only characterize partial
distributions given a practical time
in contrast our methods is able to find
and characterize almost
so this example
demonstrates the ability of our methods
to sample from multimodal distributions
and
suggest that our method can be
significantly favorable in the
non-asymptotic setting
next we tested a bayesian neural network
for image classification
we consider cfr data set and the
resonant model
from the results we can see that
csgmcmc outperforms previous sgm cmc
matters significantly by efficiently
exploring the multi-modal distribution
of neural networks
it also outperforms optimization methods
by because of basic average
because it
can categorize physical characteristics
of the distribution
furthermore we tested
a
large-scale benchmark imagenet
so from the results we can see that our
method yields the best negative
likelihood and top five accuracy as well
as comparable top one accuracy
um so this indicates that this cyclical
steps as schedule
can efficiently explore the parameter
space and diverse samples can help
prevent overfitting
so in fact this is well the first work
to make mcmc work on such large scale
deep learning
problems
so cs3mcmc opens the door for better
understanding probabilistic deep
learning so many works use
csgmcmc to explore fundamental problems
uh examples including better
understanding posterior of neural
networks
better understanding priors of neural
networks
further investigates uh what the
posteriors are really like
uh in the deep learning
and google's uncertainty baselines
library also includes these methods as
one of the benchmarks
uh csgmcmc has also been applied to many
applications across different domains
such as large-scale image classification
earth surface calibration molecular
property prediction
uh in summary uh the csgmcmc has kept
and the ability to work with
deep neural networks and the big data uh
we're improving uh deep neural networks
reliability by efficiently exploring the
highly multimodal posterior distribution
and our work in this slide also includes
metal vi where we improve the
reliability of variational inference by
using a better divergence metric
and putting this two line of work
together we have pushed the frontier of
this scalability reliability tradeoff
providing theoretical understanding
practical algorithms
as well as
enable many real-world applications
so our work have open source and there's
more information about the
implementation online
with that thank you and i'm happy to
take questions
[Applause]
any questions
for the cyclic uh learning that studios
right so did you use like an exponential
detail
we use cosine function to control the dp
um
you mean the difference between this um
method with optimization methods
like what difference does this typically
do
is just traditional activities or
uh
well so for optimization you typically
get one a single point estimate
but for
this uh cyclical sgm assembly um it
equipment you can think that
we run the sampler and we reach the mode
we collect the samples from this mode
and then we restart the cycle so the
sampler jump out of this mode and
explore
another mode and we sample from that
mode and then we uh repeat this schedule
so basically we sample from different
modes instead of use a single point
estimation as people did in optimization
quick question so i mean this is like
super common in doing i mean when i'm
doing sgd with cyclical another schedule
right so due to a comparison of like
asian method with just purely doing lgbt
with random universe sampling and cyclic
practice
i guess yes we compare with that
benefit of doing it uh yes yes it's
better than doing that because we
because because for that matter they use
a single point to represent each vote
right
but what is that let's take minivans
like not pure hd they take patches today
some bad signs
i mean is there like a generalization
benefit convergence benefit
do you have like faster convergence like
what is like benefit why would i use
this method if i can so weird
you mean your theoretical your theory
were in practice
and neither really is there like a
faster convergence right isn't it just
different like either you're getting one
single theta at the very end or you have
this whole collection of thetas like
distribution just the difference what
you do for impressions
i mean in practice we show that the
empirical results in terms of uh
accuracy and answer the estimation our
matter uh are better than uh
optimization method you mentioned
so that's in terms of the uh practical
performance uh for uh theoretical
comparison we we don't um do that
comparison in the paper but it will be
interesting to see
uh generalization matter i mean like
sorry i mean test accuracy
it has better test activities yes
okay thanks
don't that's that's it for today but
don't miss our exciting finale tomorrow